-Rita, come on over here
and let's see what singing
challenge you get.
-Okay. Here we go.
-Here we go.
-Oop.
-Magic Mic.
-I love that show.
-♪ You got to change tonight ♪
♪ When you see
those changing lights ♪
-She has to strip!
-No. I'm not stripping.
I'm not stripping.
-Is this the show? No.
-No, no, I'm not stripping,
I promise.
This is -- This is --
In front --
-They're gonna strip for you!
-In front of you
will be six microphones.
Every time one lights up,
you have to sing into that mic.
Your voice may change.
-Okay.
-Try to keep up.
Rita, take your position
and let's see...
what song you are singing.
Here we go.
You're singing "Since U Been
Gone" by Kelly Clarkson.
-Yeah! I love that song!
-Alright, you got that?
-I love that song!
Okay.
-Alright.
You ready for this, guys?
-Let's do it. Yeah, I think --
I think she's gonna kill it.
-Alright. Alright.
On your mark...
-Have my back on this one.
-...get set, go.
♪♪
-♪ Here's the thing ♪
♪ We started out friends ♪
♪ It was cool,
but it was all pretend ♪
[ Deep voice ]
♪ Yeah, yeah ♪
♪ Since you been gone ♪
-That's amazing.
-[ High voice ] ♪ You're
dedicated, you took the time ♪
♪ Wasn't long
'til I called you mine ♪
[ Deep voice ] ♪ Yeah, yeah ♪
♪ Since you been gone ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Normal voice ] ♪ And all
you'd ever hear me say ♪
♪ Is how I picture me
with you, yeah ♪
[ Deep voice ] ♪ That's all
you'd ever hear me say ♪
♪ But since you been gone ♪
[ Demonic voice ] ♪ I can
breathe for the first time ♪
[ High voice ] ♪ I'm so
moving on, yeah, yeah ♪
[ Demonic voice ]
♪ Thanks to you ♪
♪ Now I get what I want ♪
[ Normal voice ]
♪ Since you been gone ♪
♪ Ahhhh ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪